みんな日じゃあみんな八景ましたおめでとうございます肇社長です
ハイテクで新年一発目の動画なんですけども
特に何もしませんや何もしませんっていうがちょっとねあのお正月って気分じゃない
ですよ嫌味なたらいいですよみなさんお正月気分でもう前歯にどんどんやって言って
いただいていいんですけどもうちょっとね
余裕卒業がかかってきまして卒業論文ちょっと書こうと思ってたんですけども
ちょっと実は紅白の方に出てましてちょっと見えて抱かれてチラチラ映ってたくらいな
んですけどもまぁ
疎通のかけなくてもねとっても良いんでまずは売れたかなと思います
よかったよかったってよくない本当に避けがこのあーえっと卒業できなきゃいけないか
もしれないんでちょっと音表明日明後日本当に卒論
の期間なんですよちょっと動画を出せない期間で入るかもしれません大事です時で今年
の目標をちょっと走っと言おうと思いまして3つちょっとこちらも曲受けますひとつ目
卒業論文を終わるしっかりねその学生であるべきる学生である学生で学生学生学生だ
からでやっぱ学生としてし別記
もう学生ながらね学生としてすべきことをしっかりやります今年はもうそんな並ぶない
と思うんだよ
あ俺の命じゃないからね学生生活の話はもうそんな長くないのでしっかりやるべきこと
をやってちゃんとね学生を終えればいいだと思っております
もう何かも知れごめんねちょっと頭高いの卒論でいっぱいだからさ
編集技術を磨くこれでしょもう今まで通り動画が楽しく出すのはもう当たり前なん
でしょうかもう良しとしてもうちょっとね動物台のレベルを上げていければなと思った
よりは上がるかとか分からないけどいろいろ勉強できればだと3つ目は
なんかないかなー3つ目でしょどうしようどうしてわかっ
相談決めた音君たはフェアの創造主は今年の目標決まった
上がっていってもんで片付けれないので嘘じゃやめとこまで同社はなんじゃないかな
今年の目標でしょ遊ぶもん
みんなに決めてもらう良かったらみなさんこの動画のコメント欄で僕の今年の目標を
もう一つ決めてくださいあの本土選ぶから皆さんの止めて何から僕の今年の目標もう一
個選べるんでそれは今年の目標にしますよですよねちょっとバタバタしたお子だけなん
ですけどもまだもうマジ卒業した
3時はオレが世界を変えてやるからなという意味で今年も楽しく適当に揺れて
宜しくお願いしますでは2016年もよろしくお願いします
者だ
tan